if i'm your best
tuesday morning i'll run up in a thing
are you man
[Laughter]
in there
we need www
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right jeez
one people happy monday with it what are
you saying happy november yo
new month
new month brand new yeah i hope you guys
are feeling fresh feeling funky feeling
fine
and uh yeah man i made the mistake in
the last episode i'm saying that was
going to be the last episode in the uh
in this studio yeah this is definitely
the last episode in the studio this is
definitely the last one uh my apologies
i [ __ ] up the calendar um
yeah this is the last one
but as i said
i could have probably lied and said this
is the new studio true because you want
to do you even [ __ ] tell the
difference
you're not don't give a [ __ ]
you don't give a [ __ ]
um that's all there is
but yeah man hope you guys are blessed
obviously you know the drill
head on over to patreon
um
three pound a month tempe a day and you
get those extra juicy thursday eps if
you want a little bit sweeter you go up
to the tier two ten pound a month and
you can funk with us
uh once a month on zoom and uh we can
chat [ __ ] together and have some fun
um
guys same as always if you're on youtube
and you're chilling
if you're lonely and you're you're
you're you ain't
had some pipe in a while or or had some
personal while chirp sitting in the
comments man get busy in the comments
i've seen a couple people throwing some
bait out
i've seen a couple of friends on bait
out
and um nothing yet so um guys if you if
you've been trying to trap the thing in
the comments you stay stay buggy with it
yeah and um we'll make sure it patterns
100 bro yeah
yeah no fun but it's getting cold we
don't want to be out here we want to be
cool we need to snuggle we we want to be
snug snug
so um yeah yeah netflix is bringing out
some juice in the next few months so
yeah just just find that one chips thing
in the comments let us know how it goes
uh leave a nice like
if you can you know
please um snuggle up to that subscribe
button just give it a little
a little flick just yeah go to the
subscribe and give it a little
little flick and um next to that you got
uh you got that bell ring that bell
just yeah hit that up yeah ring that
bell
flick
ring
there we go and we're up
um and without further ado
who has fun facts
wakes filed for eggs fun fact of the day
right so george clooney once purchased
14 suitcases
filled each one with one million dollars
cash and gave up gave it out to 14 of
his closest friends
big man you know what for some reason i
thought i know this fact i thought it
was eight
i didn't know it was 14 14. so george
clooney credits his closest friends with
helping him to get to where he is today
and in 2013 he decided to pay them back
for all they've done literally
back then the perpetual bachelor had
just met his future wife amal and he
didn't have any kids at the time he
didn't expect to start a family anytime
soon but
what this is important by the way what i
do have are these guys who've all over a
35 year period span helped me in one way
or the other
i've slept on the couches when i was
broke they've loaned me money when i was
broke they helped me when i needed them
over the years and i've helped them over
the years too
clooney's movie gravity had just become
a hit which brought an unexpected
windfall for the actor because they
didn't want to pay us this him again
quote him because they didn't want to
pay us they gave us a percentage of the
movie
because they thought it was going to be
a flop and the end and that ended up
being a very good deal he said
clooney decided to pay it forward to his
friends he purchased 14 tumi suitcases
filled each one with a million dollars
cash he told his friends to mark their
calendars for a dinner party at his
place and when they all arrived he
handed each of them a suitcase
and he all opened it it's like gang i
will squeal gang
i was squeal fam
did you know the the t's and c's
of the million dollars
no i did not yeah so the t's and c's in
order for this transaction to transpire
one of the conditions
um was that they either all had to
accept it or none of them get it
okay all 14 of them had to accept it or
none no one gets it
another condition that he was not
allowed to ever ask what they did with
their money
they were never allowed to ask him for
money
and he was never allowed to ask them
where what they what they spent their
money on okay or how much they've spent
or
yeah yeah the money is theirs do it
please yeah let's have a sick time yeah
let's go we're all millionaires now
enjoy that hold that that's insane man
none of my boys could ever do that
that's insane bro none of my boys could
ever hand me a suitcase for a million
dollars the thing is sorry it's got you
off
you're not there are you
it's been two years you're not
ah i do it autonomously bro it's not bad
um the thing is
because all of my close friends anyway
i've got their bank details so i
wouldn't even hand it to them i'll just
just dash i'll just dash it in their
account and say put in a group chat you
man check your account
deal with it as you please don't don't
holler me and tell me what you've done
with it just do it as you please that's
how that's how i surprised you that's
live to be fair that's live but that's
when i hit you back and say fam
i owe the irs money
you need to take it back and say it was
a mistake
and then
loan me the thing in cash and let me
pattern it in my in my own little holes
you can't dash money my bank ladder i'm
behind
i'll be like that's your [ __ ] i
arrested taking a chunk
oh yeah
that's too juicy 14 mil in cash they're
the time of their lives that night uh
bro i wouldn't even know what to i
wouldn't know what the first thing i'd
do i'll break down crying that's the
first thing i'd do
i'd lose my mind bro i'd actually lose
my i'm spending at least 15 bags that
night oh without a shadow over there i
don't know what i'm spending it on but
i'm buying whatever i want wherever we
are i'm buying whatever i want out out
out
we're renting the whole spot bro bags on
badges on bags i'm i'm flossing that
much
oh that's right too amazing rags that's
the lightest thing i've heard i would
love to be able to do something like
that oh 100 i know i will i'm never
going to have that kind of money maybe
not 14 mil but i i'd love to do that for
for like my clothes oh yeah i'd love a
certain amount of money yeah yeah like
maybe like i don't know
i don't know it has to be like
significant yeah nice substantial it has
to be at least like 50.
that's juicy that's juicy i think 10 is
a bit condescending
depending on how much you you have
though this is a yeah but it's only got
what i'm saying it's like i feel like 10
is condescend even if you don't have
loads i feel like 10 is condescending
for you to think that that's
enough appreciable
to someone else
for example
jay
if i handed j 10 bags and say hey hold
up you've helped me out over the years
my g i've got something for you so what
it's ten packs
that's it
that's cute
imagine if you replied that's cute
that's cute i'll probably probably all
right i'd break down he's kind of he
he'd say i'm all right i'm actually all
right same one but that me and my
brother had a discussion this is when i
actually found out about the george
clooney thing my brother told me that
george clooney thing
whilst we're having a discussion about
money and whilst we're having discussion
about like what we'd want to do
for our friends and our parents and
stuff
and me and lawrence have the same
ideology of what we'd want to do
for each parent
our mom and dad of course and uh like
we have no idea
how much money my dad has and how much
money my dad needs
so exactly what in that terms of like i
wouldn't know how to retire my dad i
could think i've made it and give my dad
a hundred bags and be like retire enjoy
yourself and you'll be like that's cute
big man
you think i can retire with a hundred
bags measly hunter measly hundreds big
man come off it that's embarrassing that
you think that i'm embarrassed for
myself to think that my son thinks a
hundred bags is going to do me the rest
of my life
i'm surprised he's probably safety i'm
surprised you think that's enough 100 he
would blood that's nice
but like that's not gonna do me the year
nah so yeah we both agreed that we
wouldn't be able to give my dad
i think my dad said in the past like
three mil he'd need
to retire oh wow uh
i think he said about three mil
i ain't got that
i'm not gonna have that he will be long
retired by the time i have to yeah yeah
yeah so um jeez yeah he said about three
mill hood need to retire
jesus i ain't got that so yeah i could
offer him 200 300 and he'd be like i'm
not retiring i thank you but i'm not
retirement it's going to help me for a
year or two it's going to hold me down
for a bit but
that doesn't really do much for me
so you both think we would probably just
buy them something like a car
or a house abroad or some [ __ ] like
you'd appreciate that more than actually
trying to give him money yeah
um but that george many things two
swords
i don't know which position i'd rather
be in
the receiving or the given yeah because
i think that both is equally as
enjoyable satisfying satisfy is the word
i was looking for satisfying is the word
i was looking for yeah they're equally
satisfying as each other yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was sick
i think i'd rather be on the receiving
end as long as i'm part of this 14 of
course of course
rather than like i'm saying like rather
than like
me being his best friend let's say you
were rich
okay and we were best friends okay and
you gave me a meal yeah i'd be gassed
obviously
but like you didn't give it to anyone
else oh okay okay okay
like your mom your dad your sister and
me
i'll be like eyes are sick but like it
doesn't include them yeah there's me
with a meal now and there's you with
50 mil 100 ml whatever it is like we're
still on different planes and you're
basically just
doing me not even a favor like you're
just like you need this
do i mean but when it's 14 man yeah and
we're all out one wow yeah
this is mad like you're all in the same
level you're enjoying it together yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's better for george
it's better for like your own mental
state that is you and 13 other man yeah
in this thing it's not just you because
out of all his friends he thinks you
need this most and you've helped him out
or whatever and you could really do with
this milk like he's just doing it for
all of his boys like that would make me
feel so good to be part of that for me
to turn to one of you manager we're
going out tonight because if you gave me
a meal
it's not like i could be like i'm going
out tonight like it's not even like i
can take you out do i mean because you
gave me the [ __ ] money yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it would just be pointless i
hear you i hate of course i hate you you
have to have to do the same scenario
yeah you have to enjoy it with other
people but yeah i'd love to be able to
do that one day
excuse me but yeah bro oh i'd love to be
able to do that one day if you had i'm
never going to be able to do it but i
would love to it's a dream man you never
know
it's true i never know i was having a
conversation with someone the other day
though but like i kind of do know
because i'm motivated by money
but not enough
to
ever have that level of money yeah i
know i know i just don't want to work
hard yeah
i know when you i know you said it's a
number of times on here when you hit us
you never want to be rich rich when you
hit a certain point you just want to be
financially comfortable and you're done
that's why
i just want to not want for anything
yeah you're done yeah and i'm done yeah
i'm literally done i'm just cool and you
just kind of coast on you have little
projects that you're interested in and
things that you still want to do yeah
yeah but it's not like
i'm never going to be the rock
he's got 100 mil in the bank and he's
still hunting that that the next time i
don't care
now
yeah that black i want to sleep
just want to sleep and chill and train
and like do hobbies and play table
tennis that's all i want to do not play
table tennis i can't wait till we play
table tennis next i was think i can't
get my words out speaking of table
tennis i was thinking about
what other
sports related animes would be heavy and
i thought table tennis would be a good
test would definitely be a good one
because i was thinking it has to be
something competitive like where you're
someone versus someone else so how do
you mean that hippa was boxing that was
heavy
obviously haiku for me is heavy didn't
really like crew can i don't really like
kuroko no basket because it's something
i know of like i know how to play
basketball i understand it so for me it
doesn't really gel yeah yeah but table
tennis for some reason that one-on-one i
can see some serves just going west some
spins some you because anime love to
focus on one character having one
speciality yes you're going to have one
donor powerful on the straight yeah one
guy's got dirty backspin one guy's got
some next you can already tell there's
one guy he's got glasses like that and
he does a finesse backspin and it
bounces over and then bounces back onto
his side
and then the whole thing goes silent and
he's staring at you
one bead of sweat found one feeling down
and it comes away from your thing and my
man's just watching slow mo as you fall
and you have to look up at him yeah yeah
there has to be a table tennis anime
somewhere in this ether fam if anyone
knows just slide that in the comments
please slide that in the comments i was
thinking about it when you were younger
um did you ever use watch toonami yes
did you ever used to watch there was a
show on there called galactic football
yes i don't remember it like vividly but
yes i do remember watching it it was
live yes i do remember watching it was
live the only issue with it the budget
must have been low because the only
issue with it is that each character
literally had like three moves
so whenever they were doing a match
they would just make the character do
one of their three moves at any one time
uh okay and that would be the match
so once you've seen that four episodes
in a row you're just like this is some
[ __ ]
ain't nobody doing nothing different
yeah but yeah at the time galactic
football live
i do remember watching it but i don't
remember it to that depth itself
oh i [ __ ] know speaking of kids
i was um
i was in boots the other day
i was in boost every day hunting down
some kind of meal deal from i was hungry
boots is a random place family it was
random i was starving yeah i think i was
in like a i must have been a service
station or something okay there's either
boots or wheats i can't remember okay
that was me would make more sense yeah i
think it was w smith anyway so i was in
there i see one girl in her school
uniform and she's chatting to her mom
fam
she was practicing tick tock dances
while her mum's but not like
properly yeah but she was just trying to
memorize the moves yeah yeah well this
thing yeah she was trying to memorize
everything
and um
i thought at first i looked i looked at
her and i thought
[ __ ] you now broth like um
this whole tick tock thing is like it's
a pandemic big man like you shouldn't
have to yeah it's like it's pretty it's
it you can tell it's like it's a
playground requirement yeah like if you
ain't got the ticks or dancers down
don't come to school tomorrow don't step
outside don't come tomorrow i'm gonna
tell you to demonstrate
we're going to be all huddled around on
wednesday and each man is going to have
to demonstrate saturn if you don't know
the tick tock answer is big man you
ain't got boys i'm praying to go last
i'm praying to go last
so i was looking at speaking that's the
lyrics that's long i couldn't live in
that i couldn't live in that space yeah
to have to stay on top of it like that
but then i thought back and i thought
you know what
teleline has actually always been that
way
i remember when i was a youth year nine
year ten actually no yeah yeah like year
10 maybe year 11
fam
monday morning pop up to school string
bag on yeah feeling nice yeah yeah walk
in see my boys spot spot spud yeah
yeah yeah fam one of my boys yo james
welcome
well you know about that gully creeper
well you know about that gully creeper
the lingard nulling we know about willie
bounce
we know about our willy bounce gee and
i'm like what's up
i had to blend it oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know that i know that it's like
oh yeah run it
me and my jack ups and my wallabies were
shaking
was what's that
yeah run run around the wheelbarrows
real quick let's see how you do it
because i do it like this way yes these
might think they should do it this way
what do you do
yeah
yeah yeah
i know what you're trying to say because
i start i started doing it that way
i was thinking that i'm begging for the
bell
begging for the belt to ring
i can't i don't know what they're on
about fam
you best believe that night
research living room cleared out
live and running it out table with
everything i need to learn this too yeah
yeah yeah
tuesday morning i'll run up in the thing
are you man
[Laughter]
in there
we need www i'm bad hey come on fun
turns out to do it this way yeah
yeah i i couldn't remember when you
asked me yesterday but ah
yeah it turns out i do it this way oh
[ __ ] that's funny yeah yeah panda river
that implement both of them
that's funny it was scary in school time
every monday there was a new dance i had
to learn from oh that's so funny
that's so funny
[Laughter]
it was a [ __ ] track oh that was so
funny bro
i was so i was not expecting i was so
funny bro it was too intense i hated it
i [ __ ] can't imagine the pressure man
the pressure of being a you and having
to learn all them things it was too much
you have to be a man i was certain these
men were having secret meetings without
you because it was always me that didn't
know he's dancing
i remember i learned how to quit walk in
advance quick walk
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] water
yeah i had to quit in advance in advance
because i stumbled across it on youtube
yeah yeah and i was like i need to
pattern this yeah now but i already know
the last two weeks down the line these
men are going to ask me to perform
so i was in there gee i knew quick walk
from early yeah yeah when it actually
came to bang your boy was your boy was
in there he was gang sided
[Laughter]
i was there my ankles were shaping it
reminds me of the summer i think the
summer between
i have a second and third of first and
second where we all during summer learnt
how to jerk jerk and dougie jerk doggy
and cat daddy cat daddy was the hard one
family had to family you had to have
your own twang on it as well you
couldn't do the nor the basic thing you
couldn't do it that's summer i learned
from i studied i learned i was watching
video up on video upon her name and it
was just all cameras we knew we knew we
knew we had to clash
[Applause]
can you do it not
do you do it but i asked you
i remember we went to jacob's house
and we were chilling in this room and
him and everyone off doing something
yeah
i was like
hey um
you see chris brown dude that dougie
[Laughter]
this thing yeah yeah i can do it i can
do this
it was clash central god fam clasher
central we had to do it yeah it was
popping so much at that time you did not
have the option but go home somewhere
and then come back and still not know it
no that's not an option no
it's an
yeah bro
it's tough and all these [ __ ] skanks
bro we had to learn all these [ __ ]
all the skanks the migraine the migraine
the [ __ ] head shoulders knees and
toes tribal man
what's that name musical statues all
this we've got we have dj's out of spot
every day right and there's a chick
called lola she plays banging music but
there's a there's a period of time for
like an hour 35 minutes set
she plays funky bro
and it just goes off my head i'm walking
around in my suit bro
my head is just like sweating my head is
bopping i like raise the music i think
all i want to do is skank you man don't
even know
ah
yeah bro oh she plays bangers upon
bangers yeah families
ah what a time what a time what a time
indeed you had a yesterday i've got a
question for you um let me see if i can
remember the question hold on
um oh this is actually
specific for you
um
can you name me all the weight divisions
in professional boxing
why are you doing this
it just came tomorrow why are you doing
this
don't talk to me like that no i can't
for starters
right so let's run me the ones you know
there's before you start there are hold
on there are 15. 15.
right 16.
it's annoying because they've got
like
you're gonna have like
super feather
feather
all right let me see how we can do right
yeah that's what i'm asking cool
no particular order no particular order
super featherweight
featherweight
middleweight
phantom weight
wait i need to somehow
checklist the thing yeah right
go
cool right
give me strength i'm not gonna get this
try though i'll try my best right
super featherweight one featherweight
two
lightweight
it's not called lightweight
oh
it's actually not cool it used to be
called lightweight
super feather oh sorry yes sorry sorry
sorry i looked up i looked to something
else i was gonna say that yes all right
so hang on super featherweight
featherweight yeah
lightweight you said lightweight yeah
um
welterweight yep
um
middleweight yeah
is that super middleweight yeah [ __ ]
out is that super lightweight
yeah [ __ ] it now
um
bantamweight
yep
is that super bantam yep
um cruiserweight yep
there's no super cruiserweight is there
nope
light heavyweight yep
heavyweight yep super heavyweight
hold on
there might not be a super heavyweight i
think there is but there might not be
there isn't mma
um supercruiserweight featherweight
lightweight
uh
flyweight
mm-hmm
there's no super fly away there is a
super fly away how many of i've got left
two
three three left we've got three left
um so should i recap what you said
nah it's fine okay i know what i haven't
said you know what you haven't said yeah
i know i have not
i'll know if there's a if i if i say
something i'll know i haven't said it
say no more cinema um
[Music]
straw weight
nope strawberry's not on there nope
that's female mma or maybe female boxing
as well
um
i've done cruiserweight phantom weight
heavyweight light heavyweight super
heavyweight
you are three more g
are they all completely different
or is it like one in a super and another
completely different [ __ ]
should i give you hints yeah go on two
or towards the top like the smaller
weights and one is
like 75 down so like towards the heavier
weights
i give up yeah i don't care enough so
i'm going to say
i genuinely don't care enough go on i'm
gonna have done my best
you did [ __ ] well i'm gonna read the
ones you've said yeah then after that
i'm gonna read it
so you've got fly weight
super fly weight phantom weight super
phantom weight featherweight super
featherweight lightweight super
lightweight welterweight middleweight
super middleweight lightweight
cruiserweight and heavyweight those are
the ones you've got
the ones you missed
super welterweight
after welterweight which i thought you
would have said because you're getting
light you're getting all the other
lights in there yeah
minimum weight is the first one minimum
weight minimum weight i've actually
never heard of that and light flyweight
light flyweight all right cool there's
some [ __ ] is it a three too many of
them there are loads of two you've got
spoken bro
the reason why specific to you for those
who don't know you must know now james
used to box a lot so that's the reason
why i see that question i saw i was
thinking let me just thought about that
for the longest time that's right
but
after this question bro
there's something i need to show you
spoke about this in a car
this
is literally
your worst nightmare bro this is
literally your worst nightmare i can't
think of any other way to explain it but
that
so there's this video i saw
on
instagram right
and it's this caption is
hold on the caption is [ __ ]
almost caught me lacking
right all right say unless i'm ready
i'm gonna show it to you and then
i'll put it towards the
they do something um
they fly right into the chimney it's an
invasion that was not a flaw
once they got to around like thirty that
sounds like this went to grab my phone
to call my boys for backup they took my
phone they took my phone from me and so
right there i was like man i gotta
evacuate i gotta get out of here this
[ __ ] y'all can have it i'm starting
running away
no
bro bro tell me what you would do
please not what he did please not what
he did
what would you do i would think
the thing is i would never even know
there were that many birds because as
soon as the first one flies in i'm out
i will smash through my window to get
out of there if i'm from one [ __ ]
bird
one bird could not fly in my yard yeah i
will dip
i will dip
30 40 50. what if i
what if you're in your bedroom now
but you're hearing commotion in the
living room i was afraid what the [ __ ]
is going on you're hearing more the
commercials get louder and louder and
louder and louder
and you try and run through the living
room you open the door and you just see
a flock of them flying around
absolutely swarming the
drop straight on my back i'll jump
straight on my back
turn to my stomach and scurry like a
yeah
our cheeks just bubbling in here i was
scurry like a tart i would never be able
to get up
fam
i'll hyperventilate
i don't think you understand how much
i'd paid to see that fam
i will scream and scream and scream they
will dive at you
as soon as you open that door they will
dive at you
i would pay money to sneak in in a
million years
i would love to just look in the mirror
in the window like a million years could
that happen to me
i will be in the front garden crying my
eyes but garden you've been in front
newspaper i'm crying
as soon as i made it to freedom i'll
break the [ __ ] down
i think you get it bro i'll break the
[ __ ] down bro
oh that would be
that'll make my day james oh you don't
understand how much i'll make me laugh
it'll be the worst experience of any of
my life
100
that's hell that's my definition of hell
i couldn't handle it i know i literally
i couldn't handle it that's giving me
like tingles just looking at how they
formulated the thing and they
all went down there
looked very animated yeah bro it
reminded me of um
itachi
yeah it's actually his [ __ ] crows
that's exactly what it looks like some
genji shooting now bro no never
never speaking of yeah it actually would
murk me in a fight as soon as he puts me
in again juice and there's crows or as
soon as i smash him in his jaw and he
bursts into birds
they will start they can never flop oh
[ __ ] that's making me itch just thinking
about it
your worst nightmare would sweep me bro
ah i saw that unfortunate james
that's hell for him oh 100 percent
that's hell for him 100 percent that's
health for me it's the worst experience
i could possibly think thank you for
that that's literally the worst [ __ ]
experience i can possibly think oh thank
you for that bro uh i needed that right
funny
before i get into this next bit i'm
gonna need another shot okay
right right
we're back
where's that thing from where was that
from again
do you remember no there's a was a show
or is that a movie is that
w
so
i've got like a thing i had this this
came to my head the other day
almost like a dream
okay
and um
you know
so you know when we did the live show
the other week yeah yeah
and um
we had that big discussion about like
why men cheat why women cheat all this
stuff and like the motivations
and how they do it and how they pattern
it right
and i was trying to
describe
why a man would cheat
and what would persuade not persuade him
to but like
his motivations behind it and why it
doesn't and people really struggle to
like to understand when you say like oh
a guy would just like
bang a girl that's uglier than his
girlfriend just
just because yeah yeah just because
and then the next day he won't give a
[ __ ] he won't do anything like he's just
he wants his woman back yeah and that's
the woman he wants the rest of his life
sometimes he just would just cheat on
like a randomer like if he
i don't know why he just would and when
i've done it in the past it's just
well
when you've done it in the past when
everyone does it in the past like it
just is of course you don't think you
just do it it's just a nut yeah it's an
impulse yeah it's literally impulse
so i for some reason this came to me and
made me realize that this might be the
analogy
to finally
translate it in a way that a woman can
understand okay or maybe even a guy can
understand right okay
so
i imagined it as if
to be as
as
to offer the least amount of
condescension possible
okay if you imagine you're a guy
and the females in your life are drinks
and your wife the one you want the one
you want to hold forever is water to you
it's water to you from
you can live off that i like that just
that yeah yeah yeah just that and if
someone said to you bro
do you think you can live just drinking
water for the rest of life and you're
like yeah man like i love water like i
need water to live i can't live without
water like i need water i'm always
thinking about water first thing in the
morning water last thing at night water
what do i bring to bed with me water
what about bathing bro water i love
water like the water is everything like
70 of me is water like i love water
dang that's your water that's your wife
that's your soul mate water
sometimes your boy wants a fan aren't
it just randomly bro
sometimes you walk up to mcdonald's yeah
and then i would you want to drink and
then you're just about to say water
and you're like i've got options now
fans are no ice
and then your voice i'll switch
impulse
impulse yeah
yeah i don't know why i just i just
fancied it
and you drink it and you're like banging
yes
banging and then someone says ah
like how about
phantom noise like that's it that's what
you have for the rest of life are you
[ __ ] nuts that's insane yeah that's
insane why the [ __ ]
what
or if someone said
okay i'll have a fat on the ice and they
said
okay the donuts person was like you can
have this fat and no ice but like
you can never have water again if you
have it
and you know well that's just silly
mm-hmm that's just silly
no i had to give me the water then
obviously i'm not gonna go without water
the rest of my life yeah just to have
this stupid fan on the weiss
but sometimes they don't say that
sometimes they just say here you go
there you go they're just running to you
drink that and without thinking
um
you didn't think straight no one told
you big man if you drink this this could
be the last drink you ever have yeah no
one says anything like that you just sip
it and you're like gang throw the thing
out the window yeah and you don't think
again
you don't think back and think that
fanta yesterday was banging you'd never
think about it again but when you're
thirsty thirsty you've been running on
that treadmill you're tired you're
parched water that's the only thing that
can save you when you're in the the
sahara up here yeah you're suffering
water that's the only thing
that's all you want bro that's all you
want in your life
sometimes i want a shot of tequila in it
from time to time i just fancied it
sound a bit more adventurous fam
something a little bit adventure tequila
side of pineapple
you can turn that down
i'm only one man i'm already human bruh
someone offers me a tequila with a side
of pineapple i'm only one man
you gotta think twice
that's hilarious
and then you just get on with your knife
yeah you don't even think about it yeah
found next day you can't show me a
bottle of tequila oh god oh smack out
god no i don't need that again get a
[ __ ] out my
face literally literally get that [ __ ]
out of my face i don't want to see that
where's my wall
on my hands and knees
bro i'm dying here where's my water
10 10 analogy by the way 10 10 an hour
yeah that's what it is gang so anyone
out there is thinking why do men chew
why don't they even risk it why do they
do it take that analogy that's it
10 instead of that it's only when
someone says if you take this you'll
never have water again then they come to
their centers and they're like what are
you talking about that doesn't even make
sense i need water
i need water i'll die without it i need
her
jesus i need her i need her i'll die
without that i was mad i would never
choose
what you're crazy
tequila over water i won't make it two
days i would make it a day i don't think
i'd make it a day exactly
even monster i love monster bro i'll
never replace water with monster you're
mad
sometimes i fancy a monster bro
sometimes i fancy a tequila especially
with a side of pineapple
that two for one action you must be
crazy
but yeah i hope that
that was funny i hope that helped some
people
um [ __ ] that was funny okay guys right
we tried to retire the x
oh yeah you said you tried to retire
but you man weren't having it
so i've got a few eggs i've got a couple
x you said you had some as well if you
have the if you have any different ones
let me know it wasn't x it was uh oh
your fellow
yeah you're a fella are you a bird
some of mine is similar right i've got
some
right i'm gonna do what the guys think
is a ick and then i'm gonna do what the
women think is it egg yeah maybe
some of these sweet me
right
what gives men the ick
when she spits her gum out and volleys
it
see this on this
i saw that and i found
i saw that and was on my knees
actually spits a gum out and volleys it
i've never seen a woman do that but if i
did
and you hear that that connection
now i'm walking off i saw that at howl
james
fam
when she tweets radio 1 and tells him to
keep the tunes coming
[Laughter]
when she pronounces the j in fajita
vegeta
this one when she gets sad because her
star sign said so
fam
that's prominent
this one's tweeted me
when she can't believe it's not butter
[Laughter]
some people need help
some people need help right have you got
any medics on there that i didn't say
um yeah yeah when your fellow punches
holes in the wall because he's lost on
fifa i've seen that one yeah yeah um
i've got
when your fella waits for his turn to
hold the bottle of grey goose for a
picture i saw that one fam
waits his when he raised his turn to
hold the grey goose that's embarrassing
that's embarrassing wait's his turn you
know oh that's hilarious that's too much
this once killed me
when your bird thinks b2b is a dj
and i saw that oh god i was thinking
that is funny oh bro when the girl
thinks b to b is a dj
ah
when your fella runs at a pigeon and
they don't move
[Laughter]
i'm sweating i'm actually sweating i'm
itching i'm actually sweating oh
i saw that one and i was dying
[Laughter]
oh
oh my god
uh what else have i got i've got a
couple
um i think that's it
this one winnie
only certain people will get this one
yeah when he asked for a pick with wayne
lineker at ocean beach
[Laughter]
ah this one's a personal attack on you
when he keeps his body count in his
notes
that's jokes
when he says please when's asking for
nudes
no
please please
please run me the tea i'm just about to
say yeah i'm just about to say that run
me the titty please
please
i'm on my hands and knees babes please
just a nip
ah
when he dms thanks for the follow
that's embarrassing fam that's
embarrassing
i'm sweating i'm sweating i'm absolutely
dreadful oh [ __ ] i'm actually sweating
[Music]
oh
when he gets ignored at the bar
that's a peak one that's that's that's a
peep yeah that's emasculating that's
amazing
it's a masculine that's not even on it's
not on
it's not on it's on the same level of
one of the ones i said when
when you're on the bus and the bus stops
and you shake fam you shake when the bus
stops or the train you lose your foot in
that's it for you that's it for you
that's a wrap
a man said when you run to a bird and it
doesn't move you know that's the most
embarrassing thing i can think of
that's the most embarrassing thing i can
think of
you're not a man they run away from
children i'm not a man
you run out of pigeon and run it nah
i'd have to volley it i'd have to volley
it you have to double down in it you
have to double down you can't turn back
to your misses and walk back
for it to swarm at you oh speak at the
ready
that's literally the most embarrassing
thing i can comprehend
running out of burden it doesn't move
that's the most embarrassing thing
you're not i can comprehend you're not a
man you're not physically threatening in
any sense
there's literally nothing threatening
about you
shame on you
shame
shame on you oh that's funny
[ __ ] oh my god that's the funny thing
right
i love that am i the [ __ ] that's
gang
okay this is an interesting one it's not
on uma the [ __ ] but it's like uh
someone's asked us for like our opinion
on debate right okay
so
there's a group of us and we're made up
of siblings partners and friends
i think i've seen this one but
considering and the latest one to be
dumped so a discussion has started on if
i've had my rebound stroke anyone
sliding in the dms
then a debate started on the difference
between a
friends with benefits situation and a
casual thing
some said they're the same thing
some say casual means baby steps to a
full relationships others said a friends
of benefit is the better one but you've
got to be prepared to lose the
friendship if it all goes wrong and the
backlash of the awkwardness amongst the
wider friendship group is there a
difference or are they the same so is
there a difference between friends with
benefits and a casual thing
or either the same thing
um
in my opinion
there is a difference okay the only
reason why i say that
is because
friends with benefits like i have to
actually be your friend yeah yeah you
know like i've had many casual things
with many casual people yeah i'm not
necessarily their friend yeah you know
because i don't necessarily interact
with them that much apart from the fact
that yeah i'm not saying memes
i'm not sending you yeah we're not at
that level yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
literally i holly you to bang and you
holla meet her back yeah yeah that's
casual that's a casual take that's a
casual it's definitely not baby steps to
a relationship oh definitely not
definitely nah it's a casual that's a
casual thing yeah yeah it's a casual
thing so friends so fwb's that's
thursday lunch yeah you're beating
something else yeah we're actually we
actually interact we actually talk on a
haha kind of thing yeah i send you a
couple things you send me a couple
things yeah you laugh we dance whatever
and we smash yeah yeah that's that's
different those are two totally
different things calm so your friends
with benefits and casual sex are two
different things i think so
i think those well the i think sometimes
the lines blur a little bit oh for sure
because the way i see it i think it's
inevitable as well i feel like with a
friend with benefits if you want to
maintain the friendship yeah
during the sex part and after this
expert you have to be a bit colder
mm-hmm you can't be as friendly you
can't be hugging them and kissing them
and [ __ ] after the nut mm-hmm they have
that blurs down that's right there's the
lines
yeah yeah so you cross yeah
contamination in order to keep the
friendship stable you need to be colder
to them during sex whereas with a
casualty you're colder to them in
everyday life yeah but you've got a
little bit more leeway
you can be lips in yeah when you're done
you can do a little cuddle sometimes you
can even stay over sometimes once in a
while once in a blue you can even stay
over if you're knackered yeah
you can even keep and then dip the next
day and you manage all of it and then
probably still not message for three
days but with a friend with friends with
benefits after you not
get off me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
get dressed and once you're closed we
can chill and chat chill yeah but it's
sticky man it's hairless um
i've been in a friends with benefits
situation
um
but
it was one of those ones where it slowly
started like you said the line slowly
started to blur because we were friends
beforehand you know this chick as well
this is year this is back in union days
or just after we left ud
and we were friends beforehand
um started to like
not necessarily see each other but
started to talk a lot more
and then we [ __ ] about for a bit
but then we started to do stuff like we
went to cinema together i remember ah i
see and then
it slowly started to
be like
what are we even doing yeah yeah because
this is not what i wanted it's not what
she wanted yeah but it kind of
cultivated into that yeah so it got
sneaky so yeah it's not something that i
would personally recommend for anyone
like a friend friends with benefits
it's tough
hella time
casual sex is a completely different
casual things are better than friends
with benefits but friends with benefits
can bang but you need like
a written agreement
you need a declaration like borrow we
are boys yeah
when you step into my room we will [ __ ]
and then as soon as we're done we're
boys again
don't do anything as soon as i not
don't do anything that my brethren won't
do yeah don't do anything at my bedroom
with you yeah yeah yeah yeah your foo
hat now i'd call you for your head now
as soon as i knocked you out
you're not sarah anymore
when you're naked
when we're done you're flakes
i don't want to hear nothing that voice
wouldn't say
stop yeah um
but yeah
casualty that's packed lunch
yeah that's bento box yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah snacky snack
and then
bless safe oh shout you know we shout
you know
however you want to do it yeah yeah
whoever shouts who's first there's a
little pattern
um but otherwise big man you don't need
to contact me you don't even need to
have my number dm me the instagram
casualty dm me yeah there's no you have
no reason to have my number
literally you have no reason
[ __ ] that's just the way of the world
though yeah it literally is 100 it's a
huge difference mum i hope that answers
the question anyway i hope so there's a
massive pretty sure it did anyway yeah
there's a massive difference but then
they
around the sex area they cross paths
without a shadow of a doubt they will it
just depends on how you handle it
pre and post yeah you need to manage
this situation because it can get hella
messy was that a guy or a girl by the
way a girl sent that okay
cool man
right guys happy monday
see you in a few days make it over to
patreon.com
four slashes and gigs yeah mum see you
there on thursday
and yeah man boogie as always love love
[Music]